hi guys dr. Burke here in this video I'm
going to give you some tips on combining
the body types with keto and in a minute
fasting if you have all three these
together
you can really get your body healthy
fast now the book that's coming out very
soon and I've been saying that for the
last year and a half but it's really at
the last little phase right now has all
this information in detail so I'm going
to give you a couple tips on it right
now but we're putting this layer of body
types over the ketogenic diet and
intermittent fasting just to make it an
amazing program so let's talk about the
adrenal body type first and yes you
might be a combination of two of these
or three of these or four of these but
I'm not going to get into that in this
video we're just going to talk about
what you would do if you're in adrenal
type okay so you're going to do
ketogenic and you're also going to do in
a minute fasting but you're going to go
a little higher with the protein 2
instead of 3 ounces of protein you lose
6 ounces of protein for the adrenal
because you're in a breakdown mode of
protein eating a little bit more you
also need a little bit more sleep stress
reduction you want to do things to bring
the stress down you want to go long
walks you want to give yourself more
recovery time you want to probably even
take naps but try to get a little bit
more sleep on that I would like to use
the acupressure tool to my body to get
me to wind down faster you can do that
as well potassium is important for the
adrenal so that means a lot of greens
the electrolyte powder would be good but
potassium helps the adrenal calm down
the physiological relaxer mineral for
the flight-or-fight nervous system you
actually need more cholesterol with the
adrenal body type because all the
hormones that are produced by the
adrenal are made from cholesterol so you
don't want to go low fat at all
egg yolks are the best ok vitamin C
foods that's the vegetables so when you
get the potassium from your vegetables
you also get the vitamin C vitamin C is
very very important for making adrenal
hormones and just supporting the adrenal
gland itself because it stores vitamin C
to make its hormones ok ovary type you
gotta go organic completely one or two
inorganic
you cannot be exposed to the GMO foods
because when you're an ovary type you
have a problem with estrogen and if you
have problem estrogen you might be more
at risk for cancers breast cancer
uterine cancer and so those tissues are
very sensitive to estrogen and things
called endocrine disruptors which are
any chemicals that mimic estrogen
glyphosate which is an herbicide mimics
estrogen so we want to go non-gmo and
that would be because they don't label
it you have to just go with organic so
do organic foods vegetables and your
meats and dairy as well you want to go a
little bit higher with your protein six
ounces of protein are generally the
recommendation but really depends on on
how much you need personally it could be
a little less but generally it's a
little bit more test it out cruciferous
vegetables are very important having an
ovary problem simply because they are
anti estrogen 'ok okay so that's why you
would want to include them Brussels
sprouts are good kale is good kale
shakes those types of things
iodine is good too in the form of sea
kale because it's it lowers estrogen
naturally higher amounts of cholesterol
because the hormones that are made from
the ovary are steroids and they need
higher cholesterol to make those as a
precursor thyroid okay you need a little
lower protein for the thyroid because
the metabolism is so slow iodine is
going to be important so sea kelp is
going to be essential because that's the
mineral that helps make the thyroid
hormones if you ever see t3 or t4 that's
the number of iodine molecules that are
connected to that hormone and then also
if you can see calc you also have
selenium which is another mineral to
help the conversion if you have a real
bad thyroid your metabolism is really
slow you're going to have to do
intermittent fasting down to eventually
one meal a day
that's what's going to take on some
cases to get them to lose weight but
make sure that you don't go low-calorie
never make sure that with the thyroid
because you're going to slow the
metabolism down even more so the only
problem that you would run into is to
make get enough calories or enough
nutrients from
you know it has to be quite robust but
you probably don't want to do a lot of
cruciferous with diuretic the truth are
because that can deplete iodine so do
other vegetables like spinach and leafy
greens and the peppers and things like
that
now the liver if it's a liver body type
go a little low on the protein like
three ounces of protein but if you're a
big guy maybe you need six ounces okay
but try not to go too much because too
much protein destroys the liver limit
the amount of nuts that you consume it's
easy to start going crazy with peanut
butter and nuts but that can aggravate
the liver as well cruciferous vegetables
are a must because those vegetables help
repair liver function go gradual with
your fat when you're doing it omit
fasting sometimes you can overdo it and
jam up the liver and the gallbladder
just kind of go graduate that make sure
it's not too much you need some but not
not a crazy amount not as much as an
adrenal case lots of greens they'll
quite huge salads very very important
now it let's say you do one of these
programs and it doesn't feel right it's
not producing the results or the effect
then you probably the wrong body type so
sometimes I'll have a person try this
and then try this and you might find
that they do really good on this then
they're probably an adrenal types or the
sometimes it's a crossover and you don't
know what your primary body type is all
right so the books coming up soon but in
the meantime you can use this as a
guideline thanks so much for watching
hey you probably already subscribed but
if you haven't press this little button
down below and I will keep you updated